hey everybody it's michaelos from order
flows.com and this is a preview of my
upcoming webinar that I'm doing on July
7 2017 in conjunction with investor
inspiration and today I want to talk
about is why Traders fail and how not to
be one of them again this is uh going to
be part of a presentation I'm doing with
investor inspiration on July 7 it's a
Friday I'm speaking at 12:45 p.m. which
is uh was at 11:45 central time and I
believe on the thir speaker that day but
you know they got uh six other speakers
that day as well so be sure to register
um the registration link is down below
in the description or you could just go
to orderflows
docomo orderflow will give you an edge
but there's three main points I'm going
to talk about today which I'll be
talking about in the presentation is why
Traders fail and how order flow will
save you so you know Traders new to the
markets often come in the markets with a
system they bought and back test it
thoroughly you they spend weeks on trade
simulator testing it you know thinking
they found the the answer to turn their
PC into a Holy Grail then you know
everything's going well they are making
money paper trading but as soon as they
enter the market and put real money on
the line they experience a few losses
and everything just goes out the window
you know after a few bad trades they
then proceed to either try to improve
the system that they bought you know for
how many hundreds or even thousands of
dollars thinking it was their answer to
trading and they realize it's not so
they try to improve the system with more
trade filters or even in the worst case
they just abandoned the system
altogether you know so they wasted all
that time and money on a system
that doesn't work well I say doesn't
work but ran into a bad period you know
and all of a sudden now they think that
they can fix it you know with adding
another filters and you know they just
give up either they abandon the system
alog together but really A lot of the
problem is they never follow through
okay so like you know in trading you're
going to have losses here and there and
you know it just sucks when they all
come at once now order flow is not a
trading system it's the ability to read
what the market Is Telling You by
basically what's traded on the bid and
the offer once you understand how to
read order flow you'll know when the
buyers and sellers are being aggressive
when big money is coming into the market
when price is being accepted and
rejected and much more so taking a
position in the market will become
second nature to you right because the
market will make sense to you so you're
not relying on some blackbox indicator
that you don't even know what's going
into it right so you know people that
buy all these trading systems often
times don't know what the trading system
even looks at all of a sudden they think
well I'm going to filter it right they
may have spent $3,000 on some macd RSI
combination trading system and notice it
doesn't work so all of a sudden they add
another RSI combination fact you know
onto their charts and thinking I'm going
to improve it like that no that that's
not understanding the market right
there's a big difference between a
trading
system and Order flow right when with
order flow you're seeing what goes in
the market you know what's orders are
coming into the market what's being
traded what people are doing in the
market rather than reacting on oh this
this line crossed the zero line or we're
above 80% now we're we're overbought and
so we should sell off no when you see
what people are actually buying and
selling you know and how aggressive they
are really the market makes sense to you
I mean it's it's easy for me to say it
you know I've been using orderflow for a
long time and and I'm a big believer in
it you know me I'm drinking the Kool-Aid
so to speak but you know I do want to
try and convince you to give it a try
you know I I know a lot of people that
were struggling in their trading added
orderflow to their trading and it really
made a big difference you know they went
from almost giving up trading to Trading
profitably
second thing I want to talk about in the
presentation is how to profit from Clear
orderflow developments in the market as
they
occur and again you know this is what I
talk about understanding how the market
works you know once you internalize
what's happening in the market trading
just becomes easier and it's like I give
you examples like learning how to drive
a car right you learn how to drive a car
you take you know you read some books
you know you go to your driver's ed
class you read books you watch videos
and then you get in the car with the
driver the teacher instructor and you
start driving okay and you know honestly
you're probably scared you know I I know
I was scared at the first time I thought
I was going to kill not only myself but
everybody else in the car but you know
after you get that experience in driving
once you understand how traffic flows
and you know Market I say market
conditions road conditions you know you
know how to adapt and the same thing is
with trading right once you understand
order flow you know it things just be it
just becomes natural it's it's a natural
way to to trade you know it becomes
second nature right when you're driving
in a car s you know acting up in front
of you swerving right you're not going
to just pull right up behind them and
sit there and you know tailgate them of
course not you're going to give them a
wide birth or try and get around them
and and get away from them you know if
someone is standing on the side of the
street looking like they're about to
jump into the traffic you know you're
going to be aware you're going to know
how to react in case he
does and you know when I talk about
clear orderflow developments you know
there's times you know professional
athletes right they talk about being in
the zone you know where they could do
nothing wrong where they you know like
Isaiah Thomas the basketball player from
Detroit Pistons um you know back in the
the 80s and 90s you talked about being
in the zone where he could just you know
you just put the ball he could see it
going in the basket before it even went
in the basket you know it's basically
it's the mental state in which a person
performs an activity to the absolute
maximum ability and you know it's like
that in trading you know when you
understand orderflow you have the
knowledge of what's Happening Now in the
market and you'll know what to expect
next and more importantly you'll know
how to react when things
don't happen as expected happens I mean
that's a bit of a a mouthful there but
you know one of the things that
separates
losing Traders you know losing and break
even Traders from great Traders is great
Traders know that what doesn't happen is
often very more important than what
actually happens it's an intuition based
on the understanding the market through
order flow that sentiment has changed in
the market so you know what simple put
it simply you know markets
rallying everyone you know you hit this
top right I mean like especially now
okay everyone is saying oh you know
Trump's in office they've been saying
this since um you know the election oh
the market is going to sell off he's bad
for the economy blah blah blah you know
we're going to have the worst depression
ever in the history of mankind yet the
market still rallies right so if you've
been shorten it ever since November you
know you're in the poor house now but
good Traders even great Traders know
that hey you know we're not selling off
there's something more to this move
right there's an undercurrent in the
move that's happening that's making the
market still go higher so instead of
shorting it they're getting long and
they're buying it the Market's going
higher they're the ones making the money
all those idiots you know if you listen
to the TV pundits oh we're going to be
crash you know worse than
1929 yeah we're up and we're at all-time
highs Will the Market come off yeah it
may eventually I mean I'm sure it will
at some point but you know trying to say
oh you know you got to get out of this
Market go to cash yeah you just been
you're out 10% return right now you know
that's why all these hedge funds are
going under you know they're trying to
bet against what's going on in the
underlying forces of the market you know
if you deny what's happening in the
market by looking at what's you know it
doesn't get more obvious than looking at
the market and seeing what's actually
being traded that you know that the
Market's going higher and you know order
flow on on a micro scale you know you
could see that intraday you know ideally
you know orderflow trading is is ideal
for short-term Traders intraday Traders
um you know if you're a longer term
Trader order flow is probably not for
you I mean you could use it but you know
you're not going to be making great
trading decisions you know something buy
and hold for three months based on you
know a period in the order flow on a
certain day um you're going to have to
put more more of the pieces together but
you know if you're an intraday Trader
looking to scalp a few ticks here and
there a few points out of the market you
know order flow is definitely
definitely something that's going to
help your trading
immensely the third thing on the talk
about is a simple orderflow trade setup
that finds Market turning points with
very low risk you know
it's everyone thinks that you know you
got to have the perfect entry or some
people say no you got have the perfect
exit some people you got to say perfect
money management well you know order for
you put all three things together right
you could have a very good entry point
with a low risk which is what you want
you you don't want to risk a lot on on a
trade and by understanding what's
happening in the market you know when to
get out so I'm going to share with you
one of my favorite trade setups that
appears almost daily in most markets
something times it appears more than
once in a day and is very
successful and you my goal is to make
orderflow trading easy for you that uh
that's why I'm going to share my trade
setups with you right so you know what
to look for in the order flow I mean
there's no point saying hey there's an
order flow chart go on your way figure
it out yourself no you know I want you
to understand what to look for in the
market rather than just you know say oh
order flow is great and let you figure
it out for yourself no um you know I
want you to
watch this webinar Come Away with
something that you could use in your
trading you know you could go by get an
orderflow chart volume footprint chart
put it up on your screen and look for
this trade setup and if it appears then
you know Happy Days all right you can
trade around
it so anyway um register now for my
webinar again you know the the link is
down here go to orderflows
docomo or go down to the description
it's in the
description and you know it's free if
you can't attend that's fine you just
register and you'll get access to the
replay so you can watch it over the
weekend it's on Friday so um you know we
should have it up ready for you by the
weekend and again you'll definitely
learn something either from me or from
some of the other presenters again you
know there's seven other presenters on
that day some of these names I'm sure
you probably heard Ken Calhoun Rick
Sadler um you just off the top of my
head I'm familiar with those guys for a
lot of their Works um and you know
there's a lot of other guys Aaron Larry
John and William that uh present pretty
regularly there so you definitely you're
going to learn something definitely
you'll learn something so whatever
floats your boat whether you're a stock
Trader whether you're a Forex Trader
whether you're a Futures Trader
definitely sign up and you know come in
on the presentations and again you know
if you can't attend that's fine just
watch the watch the replays over the
weekend so thanks everyone and hope to
see you there on Friday bye-bye